wir kommen jetzt zum thema grenzregion
polen bela rußler spielen sich ja gerade
ziemlich schlimme szenen ab um die 4000
flüchtlinge sind dort bei wirklich
temperaturen um den gefrierpunkt auf der
belarussischen seite der grenze belarus
wird vorgeworfen dass sie diese personen
gezielt einfliegen lassen aus
kriegsregionen und dann in richtung
polnische grenze drängen um europa so
unter druck zu setzen um sich auch gegen
für sanktionen zu rechnen die die eu
gegen belarus verhängt hat
die dramatik wird natürlich noch
schlimmer weil auch helferinnen und
helfer und auch journalisten von
polnischer seite aus keinen zugang dazu
haben
polen begründet das mit einem
ausnahmezustand also sehr eine sehr
schwierige situation sehr
undurchsichtige situation die fdp
fraktion hat zwei anträge dazu
eingereicht einmal mit dem titel
massenmigration über polen mit
grenzpolizeilichen maßnahmen rechtzeitig
verhindern und nachhaltige
abwehrmechanismen sicherstellen und der
zweite antrag heißt die belarus rote
wirkungsvoll schließen das präsidium hat
gewechselt claudia roth eröffnet gerade
die aussprache und erste redner hier ist
martin hess für die afg fraktion
sichere frau präsidentin verehrte
kollegin europa wird angegriffen und
migranten werden als waffe eingesetzt
der polnische grenzschutz mit
waffengewalt angreift wer sie mit
steinen beschmeißt der baumstämme
verwendet und befestigte grenzanlage
durchbrechen zu wollen wer also eine
grenze mit gewalt stürmt der ist kein
flüchtling der ist ein angreifer und
polen hat jedes recht sich gegen diesen
angriff zu verteidigen hätte die
bundeskanzlerin den mut gehabt
2015 das zu tun was polen jetzt macht
nämlich die eigene bevölkerung vor
illegaler massenmigration und damit eben
auch
islamistischen terror vor
kleinkriminellen vor gewaltverbrechen zu
schützen dann wären wir überhaupt gar
nicht in dieser lage die kanzlerin hat
durch ihr versagen den einsatz der
massen migrations waffe erst möglich
gemacht und polen beweist dass die
aussage der kanzlerin wir könnten unsere
grenzen nicht schützen eine lüge ist und
deshalb fangen wir endlich mit dem
grenzschutz an der schutz unserer
außengrenzen ist die elementare
grundlage für die sicherheit in europa
seit 2005 hat sich die zahl der terror
toten pro jahr von einem auf 64 in
europa erhöht wer polen jetzt kritisiert
oder gar wie wolfgang schäuble die
gewalttätig bekannten in die eu holen
will der missachtet vitale
sicherheitsinteressen und deutschen
bevölkerung und er sendet das fatale
signal an jeden des boten dass die
massen migrations war für erfolg hat
dies dürfen wir niemals zulassen
2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen deshalb
müssen wir jetzt wollen mit allen
politischen und auch logistischen mittel
bei der verteidigung europas
unterstützen wir müssen ein klares
politisches signal an die migranten
senden dass wir keine gewalttätigen
kennst durchbrechen in deutschland
aufnehmen und wir müssen vor allem an
fangen auch an unseren grenzen illegale
migranten zurückzuweisen wenn wir jetzt
versagen dann werden millionen weitere
illegale migranten folgen deshalb gibt
es keine alternative wir brauchen die
festung europa
[Applaus]
ich danke ihnen
nächster redner für die spd-fraktion
league rückt
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen seit unserer
letzten befassung mit der duh
lukaschenko absichtlich herbeigeführten
migrations krise an der belarussischen
grenze zu polen gibt es keine
entspannung im gegenteil die lage spitzt
sich von tag zu tag dramatisch zu sowohl
zwischen den polnischen und russischen
einsatzkräften als auch für die menschen
die im wettlauf gegen die zeit im
niemandsland ausharren
die bewusst herbeigeführte notlage von
menschen als massenmigration und gefahr
für europa zu titulieren mit
menschlichen leiter politik zu machen
menschen falsche tatsachen vorzuspiegeln
um daraus für sich selbst politisches
kapital zu schlagen den menschen in
deutschland und europa angst zu machen
vermeintliche krisen zu provozieren oder
aus krisen kapital schlagen obwohl hilfe
humanität und ordnung das gebot der
stunde während das ist die politik von
der lukaschenko und das ist auch ihre
politik das ist die politik der afc auf
allen ebenen das verbindet sie mit einem
diktator der sein eigenes volk wegen
einer abweichenden meinung einsperrt und
fordert
mit keinem wort mit keinem wort
verurteilt sie das perfide spiel des
belarussischen diktators in ihren
anträgen viel mehr unternehmen sie den
kläglichen versuch sie eben auch wieder
herr hess asyl suchen die menschen die
unter vorspiegelung falscher tatsachen
nach belarus gelobt wurden als täter
darzustellen dabei sind eben diese
menschen die opfer und lukas schenkel
der täter
und sie haben sie eben ja sogar noch mal
gesagt sie feiern auch in ihrem antrag
die abschreckung der politischen
grenzbehörden ab und fordern dass die
strafverfahren der eu sozusagen als
belohnung dafür eingestellt werden
unterstützung dafür bekommen sie wie
immer in
brandenburg von rechtsextremisten und
ansonsten in den einschlägigen kreisen
in den sozialen medien wie immer dürfen
sie sich auf die unterstützung von
rechtsextremisten in ihren
positionierungen verlassen wenn das mal
kein zufall ist aber zurück zum thema
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
ernst genug meine fraktion hat in der
letzten debatte eu sanktionen gegen das
regime in minsk gefordert und diese hat
außenminister heiko maas gemeinsam mit
seinen kolleginnen und kollegen in der
europäischen union auch beschlossene von
lukaschenko genutzte flughafen
wurden geschlossen etwa aus dem irak
oder
der türkei und ich sage auch
gleichzeitig müssen natürlich weiterhin
diplomatische schritte unternehmen und
deshalb bin ich auch froh drum dass frau
merkel sich mit dem weißrussischen
diktator in verbindung gesetzt hat und
jetzt geht es um vieles ich will meine
redezeit nicht überziehen frau
präsidentin die weiß ich was wir in den
nächsten wochen auch in aller gewissheit
machen werden und zwar immer in aller
seriöse seriosität und mit ganz viel
humanität vielen vielen dank politik
bevor ich den nächsten redner aufrufe
sekunde dr mittelberg ich möchte erstmal
wird hier
desinfiziert und dann gebe ich ihnen das
ergebnis der namentlichen abstimmung
bekannt es war die abstimmung über den
entschließungsantrag der cdu csu zur
dritten beratung des gesetzentwurfs der
fraktion spd bündnis 90 die grünen fdp
infekt änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und so weiter
abgegebene stimmkarten
681 mit ja haben gestimmt
178 mit nein haben gestimmt 502
kolleginnen und kollegen enthaltungen
gab es eine damit ist der
entschließungsantrag abgelegt so weckt
in diesem entschließungsantrag hatte die
union gefordert dass die epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite weiter
besteht allerdings hat sich hier eine
große mehrheit des bundestags dagegen
ausgesprochen mathias middelberg spricht
jetzt für die unionsfraktion
kollegen
die anträge der afg sind abzulehnen
darüber brauchen wir im grunde gar kein
weiteres wort verlieren migranten hier
erneut als waffe zu bezeichnen und die
tatsache dass sie in ihren anträgen das
wort mensch an fast keiner stelle
genannt haben ich habe jedenfalls keine
gefunden vielleicht berichtigen sie mich
da das disqualifiziert ihre anträge und
ihr vortrag hier hat sich eben schon am
sich disqualifiziert
aber
aber die jetzt werdende koalition das
werden links geltende links gelbe
bündnis ist natürlich auch
das wertete das werdende links gelbe
bündnis ich wiederhole es noch mal
ausdrücklich
dass werdende links gelbe bündnis ist
natürlich hier darüber hinweg dass es
selbst gar kein konzept für eine
abgewogene
migrationspolitik für dieses land hat
ich zitiere ihnen nur zwei äußerungen
habe er habe kam vor drei wochen
gefordert dass wir die menschen an der
deutschland der belarussische polnischen
grenze unmittelbar in die eu bringen
müssten und in der eu verteilen sollten
der mars
herr maas dagegen hat vorgestern
ausdrücklich gesagt ich würde dafür
plädieren dass die menschen die dort
sind in ihre herkunftsländer
zurückgeführt werden das ist ein
widerspruch den sie auflösen müssen und
das werden wir wahrscheinlich in
demnächst bei vielen debatten erleben
dass sie in der migrationspolitik sehr
schwer über einkommen werden und da sind
wir auf die auseinandersetzung gespannt
eins muss in der situation jetzt klar
sein wir dürfen uns nicht erpressen
lassen denn hier geht es um ein
humanitäres drama aber es geht auch um
einen politischen erpressungsversuch
durch den belarussischen diktator dieser
erpressung dürfen wir nicht nachgeben
ansonsten werden demnächst diktatoren
darüber entscheiden wer wann und wie
viele menschen in die eu einreisen
dürfen das kann nicht sein das muss
unsere entscheidung bleiben und das
beispiel lukaschenkos darf auf gar
keinen fall schule machen
letzte bemerkung und da bin ich den
kollegen dankbar dass das hier eben
angesprochen hat wenn wir das thema
menschlichkeit und die furchtbare
situation in der sich die menschen an
der grenze dort befinden wenn wir das
problematisieren und da wirklich schnell
und pragmatisch helfen wollen dann darf
es da keine formalistisch diplomatischen
argumente geben das sage ich in ihre
richtung der nouripour weil sie das ja
ausdrücklich kritisiert haben ich habe
großes verständnis begrüßen das
ausdrücklich dass unsere bundeskanzlerin
in direkten kontakt gesucht hat ich sehe
darin keine diplomatischen oder sonst
problematischen anerkennung sondern hier
geht es darum dass wir schnell und am
hilfe organisieren für die menschen vor
ort das uhr in hcr und andere hilfswerke
dort kontakt bekommen an die menschen
ran kommen und helfen können darum muss
es gehen und dazu sind auch solche wege
einzuschreiten
vielen dank ihres mittelberg hat das
hier begrüßt den direkten kontakt von
der geschäftsführenden bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel sie hat mit dem
belarussischen machthaber alexander
lukaschenko
telefoniert kritik gab es von den grünen
außenpolitiker omid nouripour er wird
jetzt direkt auf darauf antworten kommen
meine damen und herren die lage an den
außengrenzen der europäischen union ist
dramatisch und wir reden hier über eine
humanitäre massive krise und es kann
niemanden kalt lassen wenn in diesen
zeiten menschen mitten in europa
erfrieren weil ihnen die notwendige
hilfe verweigert wird und ja wir sehen
dass das eine große politische
herausforderung für die europäische
union ist und dass wir dort auch
zusammenstehen müssen und es gibt eine
klare verantwortung dafür die man auch
lernen muss und diese liegt beim
diktator lukaschenko
und im kreml und das muss man sehr klar
und deutlich auch an dieser stelle
adressieren
nun ist offensichtlich dass es
verschiedene dinge gibt die wir dort
hinbekommen müssen und dass die höchste
priorität natürlich ist den menschen zu
helfen muss man in der situation auch
dann mit dem lukaschenko regime sprechen
die antwort ist ja müssen wir derzeit
mit den taliban sprechen um noch leute
aus dem land zu holen weil es nicht
passiert ist als es regulär hätte
möglich werden können
würde irgendjemand in der unionsfraktion
auf die idee kommen zu sagen frau merkel
soll bei den taliban anrufen ich glaube
nicht und das ist einer der gründe das
ist einer der gründe
das ist einer der gründe warum es
massive irritationen gibt derzeit bei
unseren nachbarn und partnern den polen
litauen lettland und litauen im übrigen
wäre es auch ein grund zur irritation
wenn die union nicht noch mal drauf
achten würde mitte beim nächsten antrag
zu diesem thema nicht warum letzten
antrag zu schreiben präsident
lukaschenka das haben sie nämlich
gemacht ich unterstelle mal das war ein
versehen aber auch solche dinge muss man
massiv achten bitte lassen sie das
wahllokal schenker nicht der präsident
von belarus ist und weil er die wahl
dort gestohlen hat
nun hat frau merkel das gespräch gesucht
wir haben das kritisiert jetzt gibt es
auch gespräche jetzt erwarten wir dass
nicht nur über die notlage gesprochen
wird sondern dass sie die ja
berechtigterweise und im europäischen
chor seit august letzten jahres das
gespräch mit lukaschenka verweigert hat
dass sie in diesen gesprächen auch die
freilassung der politischen häftlinge in
dem land fordert das sind so viele wie
die letzten jahrzehnte nicht es sind
sehr viele die gerade über diesen sommer
verhaftet worden sind und wenn man mit
den angehörigen reden ist ihre
hauptsorge dass in der jetzigen
situation sie vergessen werden dazu
können die frau bundeskanzlerin einen
großen beitrag leisten damit diese leute
nicht vergessen werden das ist
dass maria callas trikot war das ergibt
mehr drücken und all diese anderen
endlich freigelassen werden das gehört
jetzt genauso auf die tagesordnung denn
das ziel vor lukaschenka ist doch genau
davon abzulenken und damit können wir
ihn nicht durchkommen lassen wenn frau
merkel jetzt auch unseren vorschlag von
letzter woche dass das hat er jetzt die
arbeit übernehmen sollen jetzt auch dort
eingebracht hat und ja wir begrüßen dass
dann ist es doch notwendig dass zu ende
zu denken wenn un hat er jetzt die
anträge bearbeitet und den leuten obhut
gibt dann wird es leute geben die dort
auch als flüchtlinge anerkannt bekommen
diesen status von uhren hat er bekommen
und dann kann man doch nicht wie sie es
gerade gemacht haben und im übrigen bis
der außenminister gemacht hat von
vornherein die aufnahme ausschließen das
ist einfach nicht mehr konsistenz und
ich bin sehr dankbar
ich bin sehr dankbar dass wolfgang
schäuble gestern genau dies auch richtig
und ich finde mit den richtigen worten
auch zum ausdruck gebracht hat weil
diese hilfe zu bringen gehört dazu es
ist gut was die eu-außenministerin
minister jetzt die letzten tage
bearbeitet haben dass die sanktionen
jetzt weitergehen und verschärft werden
ist richtig dass jetzt an die airlines
auch ergangen gelang wird ist richtig in
diesem zusammenhang wenn sie das ernst
meinen würden mit dem was sie gesagt
haben kolleginnen kollegen von der afg
dann und sie sind diejenigen die zuerst
hat gepilgert sind zwei mal dann würden
sie ja auch zugeben dass sehr viele der
leute mit charme wings aus syrien nach
belarus geflogen worden sind der chef
von scharpings ist rami makhlouf das ist
der kunst von assad und deswegen der
reichste mann des landes das sie das
ausblenden zeigt worum es hier
eigentlich geht die erpressung kann nur
funktionieren wenn die hier in hypnose
vor angst verfallen und genau dazu
tragen sie bei weil sie glauben daraus
politisch honig saugen zu können das
werden wir nicht zulassen
und das wird die gesamte europäische
union nicht zulassen denn die
europäische union ist und bleibt eine
wertegemeinschaft basierend auf
rechtsstaatlichkeit und menschlichkeit
und menschenrechte die universelle brief
sind und deshalb ist es notwendig jetzt
sehr klar und deutlich zu machen dass
wir an der seite unserer kolleginnen
kollegen unserer partner staaten sind in
polen lettland und litauen dass wir
ihnen helfen dass wir solidarisch
solidarisch sind aber dass wir natürlich
auch von ihnen verlangen dass du dich an
recht und gesetz halten denn je aus
orten hin lassen wo hilfe notwendig ist
journalistin journalisten dort arbeiten
lassen das ist die europäische union das
ist die wertegemeinschaft für die wir
alle gemeinsam stehen wenn wir
demokratien demokrat vielen dank auch
nicht so weit der außenpolitische
sprecher der grünen fraktion nächste
rednerin in dieser debatte ist linda
teuteberg fdp sie verhandelt für ihre
partei in den koalitionsgesprächen von
grünen spd und fdp über die themen
flucht migration und integration
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
gewogen gewogen und für zu leicht
befunden
so urteilte einst winston churchill
einer anderen historischen situation
über das verhalten der westlichen
demokratien sie sind heute in einer
anderen situation aber in einer sehr
schwierigen die auch eine
bewährungsprobe ist für die westlichen
demokratien denn und es lohnt sich
darüber nachzudenken mehr als einen
gedanken darauf zu verwenden dass
geschichte der hintergrund aller politik
ist auch für die jetzige situation aus
mindestens zwei gründen es handelt sich
um eine form der hybriden kriegsführung
wir sollten dimensionen und kalkül
dessen was da passiert wie stark das
vorbereitet ist und worauf es zielt
nicht unterschätzen und zum anderen
gehört zu den lehren aus unserer
geschichte auch keine politik zu machen
über die köpfe unserer mittel und
osteuropäischen nachbarn hinweg keine
verträge zulasten dritter sondern
geeinten europa vorzugehen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
dieser
angriff auf die liberale demokratien und
freiheitlichen rechtsstaat der wirt
nimmt sie von zwei seiten in die zange
nämlich einerseits indem er uns
herausfordert zu zeigen wir sind anders
wir sind werte gebunden wir sind anders
als lukas schinko wir nehmen nicht den
tod von menschen in kauf und von der
anderen seite aber auch indem wir
gefordert sind zu zeigen dass liberale
demokratien handlungs problemlösungs und
durchsetzungsfähig sind und gerade nicht
schwach und erpressbar wie diktatoren
und autokraten sie darstellen worden und
genau deshalb gibt es auch in dieser
situation zwei arten die man der
herausforderung nicht gerecht wird und
das kalkül von diktatoren und autokraten
aufgehen lässt nämlich entweder wenn man
sich dem vorwurf von zynismus und
menschenverachtung aussetzen musste weil
man nichts menschenwürde achtet aber
auch wenn wir den fehler machen würden
vorwürfe an polen oder die europäische
union zu richten wie es manche in der
debatte tun und auch wenn wir übrigens
eine unterschiedslose aufnahme und
verteilung in europa vertreten sondern
wir müssen jetzt mit polen auch
uneingeschränkt solidarisch sein dafür
sorgen dass nicht der druck auf die
polnische grenze verstärkt wird und dass
das kalkül lukaschenkos nicht aufgeht
wir brauchen
wir haben für die oberste priorität
jetzt die hilfe für die in der kälte
ausharren migranten kein weiteres
menschenleben darf verloren gehen dafür
müssen wir uns einsetzen
und wir müssen lang mittel und
langfristig aber mit einer europäischen
asyl und außenpolitik nur damit können
wir solche situationen mittel und
langfristig verhindert und deshalb ist
es jetzt wichtig einerseits zu
beobachten was da weiter an staatlicher
schleusungen stattfindet der irak
versucht heute 200 menschen
zurückzuführen in ihr heimatland aber
das sind menschen die am flughafen aus
grad haben leider ist es so dass kein
grund zur entwarnung gibt lukaschenko
hält weiter menschen im grenzgebiet fest
nutzt sie als geiseln lässt ihnen keinen
rückweg und deshalb gibt es da kein
grund zur entwarnung nach meinem
kenntnisstand ist die bundespolizei mit
acht und hundertschaften im einsatz an
der deutsch polnischen grenze und es
gibt dort auch eine enge und
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit mit den
polnischen grenzschutz man macht
gemeinsame streifen und es gibt deshalb
übrigens auch keinen anlass für
stationäre grenzkontrollen derzeit was
wir brauchen ist aufklärungsarbeit in
den herkunftsländern damit sich menschen
gar nicht erst auf diesen gefährlichen
weg machen aufzuklären über die lügen
und versprechen der schleuser wir
brauchen einen wirksamen außen
grenzschutz übrigens nicht nur in
sonntagsreden sondern wirklich und dass
er ist das ein gemeinsames europäisches
interesse eine gemeinsame europäische
aufgabe weil es die voraussetzungen für
freizügigkeit im inneren ist und deshalb
müssen wir uns daran auch finanziell
beteiligen
und schließlich geht es darum dass wir
genau diese herausforderung jetzt
gerecht werden außenpolitisch ist zum
glück bewegung hineingekommen mit den
sanktionen aber die muss weiter druck
ausgeübt werden wir müssen
rechtsstaatlich die kontrolle darüber
gewinnen wo wir geordnete asylverfahren
durchführen lassen sie uns zu dass wir
diese herausforderung gerecht werden das
liberale demokratien sensibel und robust
werte gebunden und wer wehrhaft
gleichermaßen sind findet vielen dank
heute berg
nächste rednerin in der debatte über die
lage im grenzgebiet polen belarus und
wie die eu oder auch die bundesregierung
die geschäftsführende oder die
zukünftige reagieren sollte israel nach
für die linksfraktionen
[Applaus]
fährt der frau präsidentin meine damen
und herren die polnische regierung sagt
uns wir müssen unsere grenze schützen
aber vor wind fragte ich man fragt mich
magisch ein polnischer
menschenrechtsaktivist am samstag in der
nähe der pole spieler russischen grenze
von frauen kindern und familien sagte
mario schüttet seit monaten wie viele
polinnen und polen menschen vor dem tod
in den polnischen wäldern und wird dafür
von rechten in polen als
vaterlandsverräter beschimpft von denen
die wie die afg so tun als würden wir
überrannt als würde es einer
heldenhaften
abwehrkampf gebrauchen um die festung
europa zu schützen
beim außenminister maas hat sich das
leider auch nicht viel anders an wenn er
halb erfrorene und hungern der menschen
zurück und kriegs und krisengebiete
schicken möchte um wir linken sagen ganz
deutlich diesen menschen muss sofort
geholfen werden
internet alle beobachter
journalistin handelsorganisationen ärzte
müssen sofort ins grenzgebiet im
grenzgebiet gelassen werden und diese no
go area die da geschaffen wurde muss
sofort weg
an dieser die ganze herrscht kein recht
es ist eine rechtsfreie zone auch das
sagte marius
die menschen wenn von lukaschenko für
ihre schändlichen zwecke missbraucht
aber der sagt sich auch das was erdogan
von der eu kriegt das möchte ich auch
und beide lehnen sie als linke
grundlegend ab
wir lehnen aber auch die
menschenschinderei der polnischen
rechten regierung für die eu jetzt
plötzlich auch die deutsche regierung
ihr herz erwärmt ab die illegalen
zurückweisung müssen sofort beendet
werden die genfer flüchtlingskonvention
muss geachtet werden
und die grünen frage ich auch hier steht
eigentlich euer medialer krieg gegen
putin und lukaschenko über allen auch
über geflüchtete frau merkel muss
telefonieren und zwar für menschen die
aus ihrer heimat wie dem jemand den irak
oder eben die kurden aus dem norden
syriens vorjohann fliehen müssen
fluchtursachen sind auch nato kriege und
deutsche rüstungsexporte deswegen
stoppen sie endlich die rüstungsexporte
an die saudiarabische kriegsverbrecher
koalition die den jemen bomben sie
erdogan und seinen verbrecherischen
krieg gegen die kurden in syrien kommt
ursachen gehören bekämpft und nicht
geflüchtet
dankeschön
[Applaus]
ich danke ihnen
nächster redner ist frank schwabe er ist
sprecher für menschenrechte und
humanitäre hilfe seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen seite damen und herren weil der
herr doktor mittelberg schon gemutmaßt
hat was denn die möglicherweise neuer
koalition alles so tun könnte das können
sie gar nicht wissen weil es wissen
glaube ich überhaupt dürfen ja noch
heute berg und ich wissen weil wir in
dieser arbeitsgruppe waren die darüber
diskutiert hat und die generalsekretäre
uns gesagt haben dürfen wir nicht sagen
und wir halten uns daran so viel kann
ich ihnen aber doch sagen das was wir
tun werden wird sich jedenfalls ein
stück weit einem realismus test
unterziehen wir werden nämlich ankommen
in der realität des 21 jahrhunderts das
mit ihnen oftmals schwierig deswegen
wissen wir es gibt migration es wird sie
immer geben
wir müssen menschen integrieren wir
wollen aber eben auch steuern und erst
dann wenn man verstehe dass es migration
gibt und dass das integrations
notwendigkeiten gibt dann können wir
auch steuern und das jedenfalls werden
wir gemeinsam denke ich am ende tun
was wäre würde ich auch das was die
europäische union tun sollte und hätte
längst tun können dann wären wir
jedenfalls besser vorbereitet auf diese
krise und auf diese situation die wir
jetzt entsprechend haben die aber
verursacht ist das ist schon klar und da
sind wir uns zum großen teil in diesem
hause bei manchen weiß ich nicht bei
einem einen glaube ich dass wir uns
nicht einig das ist nämlich die frage
dass es lukas schinko ist ein diktator
in europa der das ganze nutzt um zu
versuchen die europäische union zu
erpressen der diktator mit dem sie
kuscheln und deswegen kommt ihr antrag
ein bisschen seltsam
ja ich will das noch mal muss das noch
mal zitieren das war frau weil die
gesagt hat hier aus allen rohren gleich
mit sanktionen zu drohen halte ich für
einen völlig falschen weg das war an dem
tag oder einen tag später als das
flugzeug mit handprothese mit
entsprechend entführt wo das ist
dieselbe diktator der immer um einen
versuch die europäische union
entsprechend zu erpressen und deswegen
ist es wichtig darauf zu reagieren mit
einer wie ich finde richtigen
doppelstrategie zum einen zu sagen wir
tun alles damit diese erpressung nicht
funktionieren kann das können wir nicht
zulassen das kann niemals zulassen dass
sowas geschieht wir müssen alles tun um
diese rote zu schließen aber wir müssen
gleichzeitig und das geschieht dann wenn
wir die rote schließen können eben eine
lösung eine humanitäre lösung für
gestrandete menschen finden und deswegen
will ich ausdrücklich und vielleicht tut
das die gesamte unionsfraktion herrn
schäuble danken dafür dass er deutlich
gemacht hat dass es uns eben nicht egal
sein kann was mit den menschen passiert
sondern dass wir eine humanitäre lösung
für die menschen brauchen also ein
doppelter einsatz
diese route zu schließen das was kalk
omas gerade tut im grunde genommen tag
und nacht das was auch frau merkel tut
alles zu tun um diese route zu schließen
um starten und fluggesellschaften dazu
zu bringen menschen nicht weiter zu
schleusen gleichzeitig aber auch eine
humanitäre lösung anzustreben deutlich
zu machen dass auch polen
internationales recht die genfer
flüchtlingskonvention
achten muss dass zugang möglich sein
muss für den hcl für das rote kreuz
und viele anderen weil das kann doch
wohl wirklich nicht sein dass wir am
ende menschen die in die sackgasse in
die irre geführt worden sind am ende den
preis dafür zahlen müssen dass es
diktatoren in europa gibt die europa
entsprechend erpressen wollen wir können
menschen zur abschreckung nicht sterben
lassen wir brauchen aber ein geordnetes
verfahren und dafür muss diese route
geschlossen werden und das das was der
außenminister was diese amtierende
regierung tag und nacht auch tut vielen
dank vielen dank frank schwabe
als nächstes spricht katja leikert für
die unionsfraktion sie ist
stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender dr katja leica
tänzerin sieben kolleginnen kollegen
herr schwabe ich habe jetzt eben sehr
aufmerksam zugehört sie haben also ein
spannungsbogen hier rein gebracht was
sie hier neues bringt werden
konzeptionell mit blick auf die
migrationspolitik aber außer humanität
ordnung steuerung habe ich das gar
nichts neues raus gehört insofern
bleiben wir da wirklich sehr gespannt
und
angesichts der lage an der bille
russisch polnischen grenze brauchen wir
vor allem jetzt eine klare lageanalyse
wir brauchen wirkungsvolle maßnahmen und
vor allem einen ganz klaren blick auch
für die menschenrechtssituation vor ort
und was wir nicht brauchen kollegen von
dfds sind anträge von ihnen die schon in
der ursachenanalyse fehlerhaft sind und
zwar kunst ständig fehlerhaft sind
in dem wort in dem ganzen den anträgen
kommt nicht nur das wort menschen nicht
vor wie der kollege mittelberg richtig
festgestellt hat es kommt auch das wort
russland nicht ein einziges mal vor
und sie tun so als würden sie sich sie
würden
sie tun so als würden sie sich um
deutschland sorgen und dabei ist es ganz
klar ihr mentor putin
der die menschen zu mehr frieren in den
wald schickt der die europäische union
die stabilisieren will und der das
regime in minsk stützt dass das eigene
land bankrott geplündert hat und herr
krupp hat scheiße ist sind sie da
jedenfalls haben gibt es ja viele von
ihnen die regelmäßig im kreml besuche
abstatten nutzen sie doch einfach diese
persönlichen beziehungen um dem treiben
von lukaschenko ein ende zu bereiten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unsere
sorge gehört den tausenden von menschen
die im wald erfrieren es sterben
menschen weil sie den falschen
versprechungen von lukaschenko gefolgt
sind das sind menschenunwürdige zustände
der leyen kinder und ihre eltern an der
grenze der europäischen union und das
ist unerträglich
unser anspruch bleibt humanitär im
gegensatz zu dem der hetze was von ihnen
hier kommt wir wollen den menschen die
von lukas schinko in einen hybriden
krieg krieg in die in die europäische
union in stellung gebracht werden helfen
und deshalb lieber geschätzter kollege
aus frankfurt
wir haben ja oft auch ähnliche ansichten
aber ich halte es schon von einer tiefen
menschlichkeit geprägt wenn angela
merkel persönlich die gespräche in
dieser schwierigen situation zur angela
merkel suchen was es da zu kritisieren
gibt das kann ich wirklich nicht
nachvollziehen die hände verschränkt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
bleibe aber auch gute hoffnung wenn wir
die beschlüsse auf der europäischen
union mit blick auf die sanktionen sehen
das auch die europäische union
schlagkräftiger wird wir haben gute
erfolg jetzt gesehen du buy back der
bank haben ihre beihilfen für
lukaschenko
eingestellt und wir hoffen sehr dass sie
den weg zu einer gemeinsamen
migrationspolitik als neue koalition
ehrung und da haben sie wirklich eine
ganz große aufgabe vor sich dass ihm das
gelingt
danke frau präsidentin ich
möchte gerne noch einen genesungswunsch
an einen polnischen grenze
übersenden der leider schwer verletzt
wurde als er die grenzen der
europäischen union schützen wurde wir
danken ihm und seinen kollegen
herzlichen dank dankeschön
der bundestag diskutiert über die
situation an der polnisch belarussischen
grenze ich hatte hier am anfang gesagt
es ist wohl um die 4000 menschen sind
die dort im grenzgebiet sich auf
verhalten mittlerweile gibt es erste
agenturmeldungen dass es sogar um die
7000 personen sein sollen norbert
kleinwächter spricht jetzt bräuchte für
die kolleginnen und kollegen es ist doch
absolutes deutsches politik versagen
wenn unsere polnischen nachbarn
zehntausende polizisten und soldaten an
der grenze zusammen ziehen müssen die
dort in 15 stunden schichten um ihr
leben fürchten weil pausenlos illegale
migranten sie mit steinen bewerfen und
sie am liebsten mieten würden auf ihrem
weg nach eur nach deutschland
und deutschland gleichzeitig weder
willens noch in der lage zu sein scheint
endlich einmal recht und gesetz was gilt
anzuwenden und sich ganz klar zur
rechtsstaatlichkeit zu bekennen meine
damen und herren
wenn matthäus wurde aber jetzt geht in
deutschland ein interview gibt und ganz
deutlich sagt wir müssen die grenze
schützen denn wenn wir heute tausende
durchlassen kommen morgen
hunderttausende übermorgen millionen
dann ist das doch ein hilferuf an
deutschland denn deutschland ist nicht
nur ein teil des problems deutschland
ist der kern des problems denn das ziel
dieser leute ist ja nicht die
europäische union im allgemeinen dieses
ziel ist deutschland und fördert sich
das erklären die ganz offen wenn die
aufgesammelt werden von polnischen
grenzschutz mit denen sie sich
offensichtlich mir unterhalten dann
sagen sie das deutlich auf die frage
wollen sie asyl in polen beantragen nein
wir wollen nach germany mit deutlicher
betonung auf money weil ihr bild ist
weil die grundlage ihres tickets 14.000
euro mit der schließung über die grenze
war dass merkel ihn ein haus baut dass
merkel sie verhält meine damen und
herren
deutschland kann nur eine richtige sache
an dieser situation tun deutschland muss
ganz klar bekunden niemand kommt hier
rein alle werden abgeschoben kein cent
aus unseren
sozialkassen kann an diese menschen
ausgezahlt werden und meine damen und
herren sie haben recht und gesetz und
auch die
menschenrechtskonventionen und die
flüchtlingskonvention hinter uns bei
dieser sache denn es handelt sich nicht
um flüchtlinge es handelt sich um
menschen die asyl in polen ablehnen das
haben wir
und ich bitte sie bewahren sind die
stabilität unseres landes und unserer
heimat vielen dank
norbert kleinwächter war das für die afg
fraktion über die beiden anträge wird
hier heute noch nicht abgestimmt sondern
sie werden erst einmal zur weiteren
beratung in den hauptausschuss über
diesen zwei redner haben wir allerdings
noch wer sich zum thema äußern werden
und die nächste rednerin ist elisabeth
kaiser von den sozialdemokraten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren das ist der afg heute
nicht um eine sachliche debatte geht und
eine auseinandersetzung zur lösung des
konfliktes haben wir sehr eindrücklich
gemerkt und das würde ja auch das pulver
der fdp nehmen die sie dass sie zur
eigenen profilierung braucht und dass
ihnen ihr gesinnungsfreunde lukaschenko
liefert unter dem deckmantel europäische
sicherheitspolitik geht die afd in die
debatte um mit bedrohlicher rhetorik
angst zu schüren angst vor gerade einmal
drei bis viertausend menschen an der
polnischen grenze die schutz sicherheit
und eine perspektive suchen aber bisher
nur gewalt kälte hunger und sogar den
tod fanden genau deshalb fällt es wir
uns heute auch nicht schwer den antrag
der afg abzulehnen
dennoch
dennoch ist es uns ein anliegen hier im
interesse einer lösung zur entspannung
der situation an der europäischen
außengrenzen zu in polen zu diskutieren
das muss uns und die menschen jedoch
nicht um politische spielchen oder gar
profilierung sagt es dass diktator
lukaschenko unter falschen
versprechungen menschen an die
europäische grenze nach lettland litauen
und insbesondere nach polen bringen
lässt wenn lukaschenko aber glaubt der
könne menschen als politisches
druckmittel gegen europäische sanktionen
einsetzen dann ist das ein irrglaube wir
lassen uns nicht von diktatoren
erpressen diktatoren die menschen
misshandeln und für ihre
menschenunwürdige politik
instrumentalisieren hier stehen wir als
europäische union beschlossen nun
braucht es aber auch eine geschlossene
europäische antwort von in erster linie
geht es die situation vor ort in den
griff zu bekommen und für massnahmen zu
sorgen die solche versuche der
einschüchterung dauerhaft gar nicht erst
ermöglichen dafür muss erstens dafür
gesorgt werden dass die schleusungen an
die europäische außengrenze unterbunden
werden entsprechende maßnahmen haben die
europäischen außenminister beschlossen
und ich danke haltung was würde das
entschiedene handeln
mit den strafmaßnahmen treffen wir jena
die von und die von der
instrumentalisierung der asylsuchenden
profitieren und die maßnahmen zeigen
wirkung zudem können gezielte
informations- und zu
aufklärungskampagnen helfen dass
menschen gar nicht erst auf das
vergiftete angebot sogar schenkt uns
eingehen zweitens geht es die
geflüchteten menschen endlich aus dieser
unzumutbaren situation heraus zu holen
und ihnen die hilfe zukommen zu lassen
die sie so dringend brauchen wir stehen
weiterhin solidarisch zu polen und den
baltischen staaten aber es braucht es
auf gespräche damit wir auch
internationalen europäische
hilfsorganisationen vor ort zum einsatz
bringen können an dieser stelle möchte
ich sagen respekt und große bewunderung
ich für alle engagierten haben an der
polnischen russischen grenze die sich so
dafür in ihre möglichkeiten dafür
bemühen die situation für die
geflüchteten erträglich zu gestalten
gemeinsame verantwortung dafür sorgen
dass internationale abkommen eingehalten
werden und es braucht abgestimmte
verfahren um vorab zu prüfen ob die
menschen asyl in anspruch nehmen können
oder sicherheit zurückgeführt werden
kommen sie bitte zum ende und drittens
und letztens möchte ich sagen wir
brauchen nun endlich eine gemeinsame und
auch solidarität humanität und
gegenseitige fürsorge beruhende
flüchtlings und migrationspolitik in
europa einheitlich auch kommunen und
regionen ermöglicht frauke lehnte eine
perspektive zu geben ich wünsche mir
dass von der neuen bundesregierung
diesen weg was ich dafür einsetzt vielen
dank danke in diesem fall und während
die abgeordneten hier diskutieren gibt
es schon neuigkeiten laut der agence
france press deiner nachrichtenagentur
schreibt dass die führung in linz sagt
dass es eben momentan um die 7000
migranten in belarus gibt davon will
belarus 5000 zurückschicken die anderen
2000 werden
für die soll es einen humanitären
korridor nach deutschland gegeben
dafür werde sich auch bundeskanzlerin
merkel mit der eu
darüber verhandeln allerdings gibt es
noch keine bestätigung von deutscher
seite jetzt hier weiter mit dem letzten
redner in dieser debatte thomas anders
handeln der winter ist auch keine
überraschung wo ist denn die frühe
beobachtung solcher entwicklungen
wo ist das monitoring sozialer medien
auch kaum gestützt um diese bewegungen
früher zu erkennen wir müssen ja
deutlich besser deutlich innovativer
werden wieder einmal laufen wir die
entwicklung nur hinterher mit
katastrophalen folgen und großem leid
für viele menschen
was wir schon vor monaten gebraucht
hätten wäre eine kommunikationsoffensive
und das ist die verantwortung des
außenministers eine
kommunikationsoffensive den
herkunftsländern dass niemand auch diese
kriminellen schlepper hereinfällt und
dass dieser weg über belarus eine
sackgasse ist
klar müssen und wir haben es heute die
sehen wir nach belarus fliegen kann und
wer sich noch in der region minsk auf
hält der kann auch wieder zurück fliegen
heute ist der erste rückflug in irak und
das müssen wir auch unterstützen dazu
brauchen wir weitere flüge auch die
türkei und andere länder bis sind auch
mehrere tausend menschen noch nicht
glaube dass das die situation vor ort
entlastet aber im grenzbereich geht es
um menschen in not und die brauchen
unmittelbar jetzt zugang zu humanitärer
hilfe und das finde ich es kollege
nouripour wirklich zynisch dass
ausgerechnet die grünen die kanzlerin
für das gespräch mit dem diktator
lukaschenko kritisiert für die
humanitäre lage ist nur er selbst
verantwortlich und wer sie verbessern
will der sie verbessern will der muss
eben diese gratwanderung machen und das
sollten sie respektieren und nicht
kritisieren weil die lage ist eben so
ernst dass man glaube ich irre story
buch zur seite legen muss und in der
realität ankommen oder kriege die lage
der redezeit es auch ernst ja wohl wie
kommen wir zum schluss
meine damen und herren wer sich nicht
erpressen lassen will wir jetzt die
falschen signale setzt der wer sich
erpressen lässt er jetzt die falschen
signale setzt auch mit stichwort
spurwechsel vergrößert das leider auch
die migrations routen humanität
steuerung ordnung und begrenzung des
muss auch in zukunft die richtschnur
unserer politik sein und dadurch die
union dafür vielen dank thomas ernst
damit schließt sich die aussprache
willkommen zum antrag der fraktion der
afg auf drucksache 86 mit dem titel
massenmigration über polen mit
grenzpolizeilichen maßnahmen rechtzeitig
verhindern und nachhaltige
abwehrmaßnahmen sicherstellen die
fraktion der fdp wünscht abstimmung in
der sache die fraktionen der spd von
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp wünschen
überweisung in den hauptausschuss wir
stimmen jetzt nach ständiger übung
zuerst über den antrag auf ausschuss
überweisung ab und deswegen frage ich
sie wer stimmt für die beantragte
überweisung
dankeschön wer stimmt dagegen
dankeschön der enthält sich bei
gegenstimme der afg und zustimmung aller
anderen fraktionen des hauses ist damit
die überweisung beschlossen dass da
endlich mal wirklich gegengesteuert wird
aber sommer und sommer und ferien und
ferien verstreichen und die
bundesregierung tut nichts das ist ein
schlag ins gesicht der familien kollegin
politik
viele bildungseinrichtungen sind für den
drohenden corona winter nicht geordnet
und benötigen unverzüglich eine pandemie
gerechte ausstattung und es ist ja schön
dass sich hier anscheinend alle
fraktionen angebt einig sind dass die
bildungseinrichtungen möglichst offen
gehalten werden sollen aber warum
passiert denn da nichts luftfilter
kommen nicht in den schulen es gibt
keine ideen für zusätzliche räume für
kleinere lerngruppen nichts wurde
unternommen um endlich mehr fachkräfte
zu gewinnen und die tablets und laptops
die so essenziell sind wenn das zur
quarantäne oder wechsel modellen kommt
die kommen ja wirklich nur in
homöopathischen dosen in den schulen und
familien an und auch bei den ländern ist
ja keine klare linie zu erkennen maske
auf in berlin maske runter in nrw nach
gefühlten 100 corona gipfeln gibt es
immer noch keine klaren vorgaben das ist
völlig irre wir müssen jetzt
wir müssen jetzt alles daran setzen die
junge generation die sich noch nicht
impfen lassen kann um jeden preis zu
schützen wir müssen eltern die sorge
nehmen dass ihre kinder in den
bildungseinrichtungen nicht geschützt
sind es braucht einen plan wie die kitas
und schulen pandemie festgemacht und
möglichst offen gehalten werden können
und eine perspektive wie die sozialen
und psychischen folgen der pandemie
bewältigt werden können das ist jetzt
der druck der bundesregierung
das ist der job einer bundesregierung
der alten übrigens ganz genauso wie der
neun machen sie endlich ihre arbeit
vielen dank vielen dank nicole wolke
[Applaus]
und die nächste rednerin in dieser
debatte ist ulrike bahr sie ist nicht
nur abgeordnete sondern im nicht
bundestags leben auch lehrerin
[Musik]
präsidentin liebe kollegen und
kolleginnen wenn wir ganz sogar
aufgehört haben kinder zu sein dann sind
wir schon tot das sind die worte des
deutschen schriftstellers michael ende
des autors der unendlichen geschichte
die frage wann kinder wieder kinder sein
dürfen beschäftigt mich und ist einer
der gründe warum wir hier debattieren
denn kinder hatten in der tat in den
vergangenen 18 monaten nur sehr wenige
möglichkeiten kind zu sein und kinder
wurden zu hause isoliert kinder können
nicht richtig lernen kinder dürften
nicht mehr kind sein kurzum kinder sind
seit beginn der pandemie sie haben
gelitten und zwar sehr
dafür waren vor allem die folgen der
schul und kita schließungen aber die
flächen deckende schließen von schulen
und kitas wird zukünftig keine option
mehr sein auch nicht bei dramatischen
infektionsgeschehen nur dann wenn es in
einer einrichtung ein akutes
ausbruchsgeschehen gibt welches nicht
unter kontrolle zu bekommen ist kann
eine schule oder eine kita vorübergehend
geschlossen werden so sieht ist der neue
gesetzentwurf zum infektionsschutzgesetz
vor
[Applaus]
wenn wir eines aus dem fernen gelernt
haben dann dass flächendeckende schul
und kita schließungen nicht erste mittel
der wahl sein können um diese pandemie
zu besiegen der preis dafür ist zu hoch
als ehemalige lehrerin weiß ich wenn wir
den kindern die schule wegnehmen richten
wir schäden an die nur schwer zu
reparieren sind und es ist mittlerweile
ab dass es zahllose kinder mit
psychischen problemen gibt die auch die
schließungen zurückzuführen sind unser
geschäftsführende
bundesfamilienministerin christine
lambrecht brachte es auf den punkt
schulen und kitas müssen offen bleiben
damit psychische belastungen einsamkeit
bewegungsmangel und lernen rückstände
sich nicht weiter vergrößern aber es
sieht aber
es sind nicht nur die kinder die unter
folgen der schließungen leyen auch das
unverständnis der eltern steigt die
kritik der eltern wendet sich dabei
nicht gegen die korona maßnahmen sie
richtet sich vielmehr dagegen dass
kinder und jugendliche
unverhältnismäßig benachteiligt werden
und auch kinder als die schlagen alarm
kinder sind keine infektions treiber die
am montag veröffentlichte studie der
kultusministerkonferenz wird noch
konkrete
kinder sind nicht die die in erster
linie dass wir so breiten aber sie
leiden eindeutig am meisten und waren
frank von ihr von dem wir fängt man
endlich an darauf zu hören in sidenten
bei kindern und erwachsenen werden sehr
verschieden wahrgenommen aus drei
gründen bedarf es bei der insolvenz bei
kindern und jugendlichen eine erklärung
erstens
kinder und jugendliche werden sehr
selten schwer krank schon alleine aus
diesem grund hat die inzidenz völlig
andere auswirkungen als bei erwachsenen
zweitens kinder und jugendliche werden
regelmäßig in kitas und schulen getestet
es gibt in deutschland keine gruppe die
systematisch besser erfasst wird und
drittens ungeimpfte erwachsene lehnen
oft meist nicht nur die impfung sondern
auch die korona maßnahmen ab einen tick
zu meiner ganz rechten seite reicht für
diese erkenntnis vorliegt aus ungeimpfte
kinder hingegen halten sich meist an die
vorgaben darum kann eine fläche die
schließung von kitas und schulen auch
bei höheren sidenten keine option mehr
sein es gibt nur eine möglichkeit aus
der pandemie impfen impfen die
erwachsenen und jugendlichen der weg in
die normalität wird noch lang aber wir
haben es selbst die werkzeuge in der
hand um worst case szenarien zu
unterbinden sie heißen mehr tests der
impfungen und endlich wieder eine
konsequente nachverfolgung von
infektionen bis wir ein stabiles niveau
erreicht haben der antrag der
linkspartei zählt allerdings
entschuldigung since werkzeuge auch die
bereits realität sind von schnelltests
über medizinische maße bis hin zu
angeboten für das personal all das ist
bereits teil des alltags an deutschen
schulen und das mit einem sehr hohen
engagement vor ort und hierzu auch der
appell liebe lehrer/innen und
erzieher/innen an den kitas liebe eltern
der schlüssel um deutschlands schulen
und kitas gut durch den winter zu führen
liegt darin dass sie sich alle impfen
und demnächst auch postern lassen nur so
stellen wir wirklich sicher dass wir nie
wieder über dieses thema streiten müssen
das ist der beste schutz für kinder
beenden wir diese unendliche geschichte
um schließungen von kitas und schulen
und geben wir unseren kindern ihr leben
zurück zu haben ist sie sich auch
verdient vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich danke ihnen nächste rednerin für die
cdu csu fraktion
kathrin staffler
[Applaus]
der vielen dank für euer präsidentinnen
ich liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
überraschend tut es mich ja nicht dass
die linksfraktionen die zeit die sie
heute im plenum hat dafür nutzten den
antrag vorzulegen der komplett die
verfassungswirklichkeit im
bildungsföderalismus
ausblendet und zwar konsequent
wir kennen das das man überrascht nicht
wir haben das jetzt vier jahre schon so
gesehen mindestens vier jahre
ich bin mal gespannt was sie machen wenn
die zukünftige links gelbe regierung den
bildungsföderalismus ist so wie er ist
unkenntlichkeit aufgeweicht oder
abgeschafft da kommen sie echten stress
sie kommen in der echten stress da
müssen sie sich mal was neues überlegen
auch das mag stimmen eine so viel dazu
hätten und dann was mich hingegen schon
verwundert ist dass gerade sie als
linksfraktion mehrkämpfer bei den
schutzmaßnahmen für kinder und
jugendliche fordern da muss jetzt an der
stelle schon einmal nachfragen war es
nicht der freistaat thüringen also
geführt unter einer linksfraktion
regierung die die korona testpflicht im
september an schulen beendet hat und das
tragen von masken im unterricht ab der
fünften klasse einfach wegfahren hat
lassen also anstatt jetzt hier im
bundestag eine scheindebatte zu führen
würde ich sagen sollten es doch viel
lieber mal da ansetzen wo die
verantwortlichkeiten auch liegen
vielleicht haben sie mit irgendeiner
partei verwendenden thüringen sprechen
dass sie vor ort mehr tempo machen bei
da sind sie nämlich zuständig dafür dass
unsere schulen sichere orte sein
abgesehen davon
sind wir uns glaube ich über die
parteigrenzen hinweg einig dass die
aufrechterhaltung von präsenz betrieb an
den schulen natürlich das gebot der
stunde ist ich möchte an der stelle im
übrigen auch mal eine lanze brechen für
unsere kommunalpolitiker vor ort die
versuchen da vor ort alles wirklich
alles dass das gelingt im präsenz an den
schulen ich kenne keinen
verantwortlichen in den gemeinden in
meinem wahlkreis der netzer zeit
stundenlang am tag damit verbringt dass
sie die lage einigermaßen im griff
behalten sei es mit blick auf die
ausreichende versorgung mit
testmöglichkeiten das organisieren von
betreuungs und lehrkräften zusätzliche
räumlichkeiten und so weiter und so fort
man könnte die liste beliebig fortführen
das ist eine echte mount aufgabe für
unsere kommunen und deswegen möchte ich
an der stelle einfach mal ein großes
dankeschön sagen an die verantwortlichen
dieser sehr umsichtig damit umgehen und
und anstatt dass man den ländern
weiterhin den notwendigen
instrumentenkasten an die hand gibt dass
sie passgenau dass sie effektiv auf die
pandemie reagieren können schenken die
ampel fraktionen mit dem beschluss heute
die nichtverlängerung der epidemischen
lage von nationaler tragweite die länder
genau in diesen handlungen